NARRATOR: Neil and James search
a shipwreck for the mega shark
big bull, and other
large bull sharks
that may be her descendants.
James, you okay?
I'm good over here.
NARRATOR: Bull sharks have
a pack-like mentality,
and swarm around possible food.
They surround the divers.
[panicked yelling]
I'm right behind you.
Let's get to cover.
NARRATOR: Neil and James nestle
into the wreck for protection.
Yep.
One's on your right.
NARRATOR: Now, to get
some measurements.
Neil, I'm going
to try and laser it.
Get closer.
NARRATOR: James's two lasers
work like an electronic ruler
to confirm the
size of the bulls.
If one is close to 10 feet long,
it could be Big Bull, possibly
the largest shark alive.
I've got the laser.
I've got it locked on.
Laser locked on.
I've got it.
I've got the shot.
NARRATOR: There.
Multiplying the 6 inch long
distance of the lasers,
they estimate that
this shark is young.
From snout to the curve of
the tail, a little over 5
feet long.
But nearby--
There's a big bull
shark over there.
I'm going to try and
get our laser on it.
I've got him.
NARRATOR: A giant,
pushing 9 feet.
Only inches smaller than
Big Bull was in 2012.
They get more measurements.
NARRATOR: But the strong
current, with this many sharks,
turns this dive dangerous.
Hey Neil, let's head up.
This current is going to carry
me to England, otherwise.
I'm with ya.
How about that?
That was epic.
Loads of bull sharks.
Some nice-sized bulls.
Not as big as Big Bull, but I
feel really good about this.
It's a good starting point.
We've taken the search
to the next level.
NARRATOR: They've
confirmed bulls
as large as those reported by
local divers and fishermen.
While they're not quite
the size of Big Bull,
this is her territory.
And if Neil's theory
is right, the sharks
here may be her offspring.
[music playing]